D
THAT THEY WILL NOT SAY DEMOCRATS
AND THE MIDTERMS.
JOINING ME NOW, FORMER SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE, NEWT GINGRICH AND
THE AUTHOR OF THE UPCOMING BOOK
"DEFEATING BIG GOVERNMENT
SOCIALISM" AVAILABLE FOR
PREORDER NOW.
NEWT, THOSE PEOPLE ARE GROWING
THE MOST ABOUT THIS.
THIS TINY WING GRASP ON
DEMOCRACY ARE THE ONES WORKING
TO UNDERMINE IT.
>> LET ME SAY FIRST OF ALL, I
THOUGHT YOUR OPENING MONOLOGUE
WAS BEYOND TERRIFIC.
I THOUGHT YOU CAPTURED EXACTLY
WHERE WE ARE, NOT JUST HERE, BUT
AROUND THE WORLD.
THE WHOLE EFFORT BY THE ELITES
TO HOLD ONTO POWER NO MATTER
WHAT.
LOOK AT THEM AND HERE'S THE FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY APPARENTLY HAVE SIGNALED
THAT THEY KNOW IN ADVANCE THAT
TOMORROW'S INFLATION NUMBERS ARE
GOING TO BE STAGGERING.
THEY HAVE THIS GAME WHERE THEY
TALK ABOUT PUTIN'S PRICE HIKE.
NOBODY BELIEVES THAT.
THE AVERAGE EVERYDAY VOTERS,
WHETHER THEY ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN, LATINO, WHITE,
ASIAN, IT IS A MATTER.
THEY'RE GOING TO THE GAS
STATION, THEY ARE TRYING TO FILL
UP THEIR TANK.
LAST TIME I DID IT IT WAS $92.
THEN GOING TO THE GROCERY STORE.
TRYING TO BUY GROCERIES.
EVERYTHING IS MORE EXPENSIVE.
I DON'T CARE HOW THE DEMOCRATS
MESSAGE IT.
HOW WILL WE GET PEOPLE TO BE
MORE FRIGHTENED OF SOME
THEORETICAL PROBLEM --
DONALD TRUMP IN 2024 -- THAN THE
REALITY, THAT PEOPLE ARE
WATCHING THE SYSTEM BREAKDOWN.
THEY ARE WATCHING 18,000 PEOPLE
PER DAY PROJECTED TO COME ACROSS
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THAT'S THE CITY OF ATLANTA EVERY
SINGLE MONTH.
THERE WATCHING RISING CRIME
RATES, RISING CARJACKINGS, AND
THEY'RE LOOKING AROUND THINKING
NONE OF THIS IS WORKING!
THE DEMOCRAT PROBLEM IS THAT YOU
CAN'T SCARE PEOPLE ENOUGH WITH
SOME POLITICAL THEORY WHEN THERE
ALREADY BEING FRIGHTENED BY THE
REALITY YOU HAVE CREATED.
>> Laura: TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
THIS MESSAGING NEWS, MSNBC,
DECIDED TO DRAG OUT
NEW YORK CITY'S WORST MAYOR TO
OFFER HIS AND TRENCH PERSPECTIVE
ON IT.
>> JOE BIDEN IS A GOOD
MESSENGER.
YOU CAN RELATE TO HIM ACROSS THE
IDEOLOGICAL SPECTRUM.
HE ACTUALLY HAS THE ABILITY TO
REACH EVERY DAY WORKING PEOPLE.
WHAT WE ARE NOT HEARING IS A
MESSAGE.
I ASKED AROUND THE TABLE WHAT'S
THE DEMOCRAT MESSAGE RIGHT HERE
HAVE A YEAR FROM ELECTION, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE MESSAGES.
>> Laura: I'M GOING TO BURST
OUT LAUGHING ON NATIONAL TV,
BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY THINK THEY
HAVE A MESSAGING PROBLEM.
THEY DON'T THINK THERE IS A
SUPPLEMENTAL PROBLEM THERE.
>> THAT SUCH A LOW BLOW.
BILL de BLASIO'S ARGUABLY THE
WORST MAYOR IN THE HISTORY OF
NEW YORK.
ISAAC IT'S FAIR TO SAY
THAT BIDEN'S WORKING HIS WAY TO
BEING THE WORST PRESIDENT IN THE
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES AND
CERTAINLY I THINK KAMALA HARRIS
HAS ALREADY WON THE AWARD AS THE
DUMBEST
PERSON EVER ELECTED
VICE PRESIDENT.
BUT TO BRING BILL de BLASIO
OUT TO DEFEND JOE BIDEN.
I THINK IT'S JUST CRUELTY.
>> Laura: GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT AS ALWAYS.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO READING YOUR
BOOK.
WAIT, I'VE TIME FOR ONE MORE
QUESTION.
OH, YEAH, YOUR NEW BOOK AND THIS
IS WHEN I WANTED TO ASK YOU
ABOUT.
THE SCREEN WENT BLANK, BUT IT'S
COMING OUT IN JUST A SHORT
WHILE.
YOUNG PEOPLE ESPECIALLY, I THINK
THEY NEED TO READ THIS BOOK
BECAUSE ALL DAY HERE IN SCHOOL
TOO OFTEN IS THAT GOVERNMENT
WILL TAKE CARE OF THE PROBLEM.
IF WE ONLY HAD MORE GOVERNMENT
SPENDING WE WILL SAVE THE
PLANET.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT NOW?
>> IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE WHEN
WE DID SOME WORK ON THE AMERICAN
MAJORITY OF PROJECT WE FOUND
THAT IF YOU'VE CREATED
FREE-MARKET CAPITALISM AGAINST
BIG GOVERNMENT SOCIALISM, IT WAS
59-16 THAT PEOPLE HAVE A CHOICE.
IF YOU ASK SWING VOTERS IT WAS
82-18 AND THE REASON IS YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT HAVE SAID IT
SOUNDS GOOD TO COME OUT YOU PUT
BIG GOVERNMENT WITH SOCIALISM.
THEY GO, ARE YOU CRAZY?
THEY HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA.
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T WORK.
IT'S A HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY,
HUGE BUREAUCRACIES, AND VERY ILL
PRODUCT.
A GOVERNMENT SOCIALISM IS THE
BEGINNING OF THE END OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS A SERIOUS
COMPETITOR.
>> Laura: LET'S SEE IF THE
NATIONAL LIBRARY ASSOCIATION
ACTUALLY GETS YOUR BOOK IN THE
SCHOOL LIBRARY